Jarrid I'm just logging in here I'm
excited to be here so tonight my talk is
titled a common model separated by two
disciplines Bayesian factorization
machines with Stan and our I'm gonna
hold
testing testing good
I'm Adam Loretta and so tonight we'll be
talking about factorization machines
I'll go through what they are how we fit
them and I'll first simulate the data
generating process for this model and
illustrate some Stan code for how to fit
them and I'll start with a sort of
simple straightforward model and then
we'll extend this to a hierarchical
model finally we'll end with some real
data analysis and I'll show you some of
the cool plotting you can do with this
model so Who am I I'm the senior data
scientist at just capital and I just
want to note that all views are mine
alone they don't represent my employer
or any of its funders or anyone other
than me I received my PhD in political
science from the Ohio State University
and I got my bachelor's in political
science from Grinnell College and I've
worked on word embeddings causal
inference Bayesian stats discrete choice
models and I'm more than happy to talk
about any of those with anyone who cares
- chatter listen so I wanted to start
off thinking about what why we model so
I think if there is basically being like
three reasons you might model data
descriptive inference you want to know
is there an association between x and y
prediction you have some covariance and
an outcome in you want to know what is
your outcome for a new set of covariance
and causal inference where you want to
know does changing X change Y and I've
got a book chapter where I talk about
this in a little more detail and I think
sort of thinking about why you model can
help inform the sorts of models you
choose to use and one set of models that
I think you know can also fit in this
framework that I'm going to extend
tonight are latent variable models and
for unsupervised models where the idea
is
you're learning parameters to
reconstruct your observed data if you're
coming out of computer science you're
probably doing this for a prediction if
you're a social scientist you're doing
this for inference so you've probably
encountered these models in some form or
another principal components analysis
factor analysis other matrix
factorization models type yield point
models if you've ever read 538 and CDW
nominate that's an ideal point model or
worth to vet for word embeddings and the
basic idea behind all of these models is
you have some data matrix X with n rows
and J columns
it'll be decomposed into two low rank
matrices and I'll call these gamma which
is n rows by K columns and Delta which
is K rows by J columns and then
depending on the assumptions you'll make
about the structure of gamma and Delta
you can get a variety of different
models factorization machines are earned
it cool because they combine both
supervised and an unsupervised model
it's a regression on your observable
data with a latent variable model on
your residuals and you can plug and play
with any generalized linear model and
you may say to yourself why and the
answer will start with a little
explanation so if you have a regression
model for one observation you have
category categorical predictors say
country year data you have an outcome
why yet the parameters you'll estimate
beta and you have an error term and so
if you're running this fixed effects
regression in R this is what your model
looks like ln factor group 1 plus factor
group 2 but say you want to interact
these so you now have factor Group 1
plus factor group 2 plus group 1 times
32 and so you'll have a parameter for
every interaction in addition to each of
your main effects problem is that you
can only estimate this beta 3 for your
observed interactions and that as N and
J grow you have an additional and
parameters for every J at and vice versa
so this connect you can get a parameter
explosion really quickly and they can be
pretty poorly estimated if you don't
have many observations in any
these groups so the solution is a
factorization machine where you replace
beta three with the dot product of low
rank weighting factors continuing with
the notation from before if you have two
groups Group one will be gamma which is
n by K and group two will be delta which
is J by K and then beta three before it
what is now gamma times delta transpose
so this gives you a scalar that's then
added to your coefficients in the model
estimation so this is what your
regression model now looks like so you
have your outcome your main effects and
then your interaction term here and so
the interaction is just a scalar adding
into this model so the advantage of this
is that the low rank structure
regularizes the interaction term that is
you have a set of parameters you're
learning and they're constrained as they
grow and you don't need to observe an
interaction to predict it you can get an
interaction as long as you identify a
member of each group and so the basic
factorization machine model here we have
our outcome model where which is
normally distributed we have our two
main effects we have our dot product and
here throughout this unless I otherwise
know that I'm assuming our Y is normally
distributed and continuous and you have
so you'll have a standard deviation your
beta coefficients on your main effects
are distributed normally with Amina zero
in some standard deviation and then your
interact the elements of your
factorization matrix are distributed
normally with a mean of 0 and a standard
deviation of 1 all these slides will be
available online and I think they're
available now actually so each element
of this factorization matrix is
distributed normally and we're assuming
no structure about their correlation
here so one of the bits of advice I was
given as a graduate student is whenever
you see a fancy new method and you want
to learn how to use it
simulate data from it like write down
what the data generating process
so all the code in here is also
available in a git repo and much like a
cooking show where they chop up the
onions in advance and just have them
prepped in bowls all the code year has
been sort of portioned out so it looks
nice but it's all available in the
scripts you can run online so what we'll
do is we'll set the number of levels for
each of our co-variance here we'll do
100 for our first group it's 20 for our
second and number of latent dimensions
will be 5 so what we'll do is we'll use
the expanded grid command which is this
really great command if you're ever
working with categorical data it'll give
you every combination of two factors and
so then we'll use the sparse model
matrix to create a matrix for all of
these factors and then combine them so
that what we have is a two column matrix
with our indices and so the advantage of
this is it's very lightweight in terms
of memory because it's only growing long
it's not growing wide and so this will
be useful when we fit them all
understand in a few moments to simulate
our regret and part of the equation will
draw some betas and then we'll multiply
our X's times our simulated betas and we
get this linear predictor term and so
this is basically if you wanted to
simulate an OLS model how you do it next
okay next we'll simulate our latent
factors and what I'll use here is a
distribution known as an lkj
distribution and what this is is a
distribution over correlation matrices
so this ADA term is the sort of tuning
parameter of the model and it's bounded
0 to positive infinity and as it goes to
positive infinity it collapses over an
identity matrix if it's one it's just
uniform correlation matrix so you'll
have a diagonal of ones and that off
diagonal will range
negative one to one and so we'll get our
correlation terms here and then we'll
use will simulate a multivariate normal
using that correlation matrix and a mean
of zero for each of our latent factors
and then what we'll do is we'll go
through and get each of our terms from
our predictor matrix before take their
dot product increases factored terms
matrix which will be anytime jay
williams by one column and then we'll
add our linear predictor a little bit of
noise to the model so that's just our
random error term noise so i fit these
models and stamens stan is a
probabilistic programming language what
that means is that the variables in Stan
are associated with distributions and it
provides a way to estimate your models
and fit them so it's incredibly powerful
for Bayesian modeling and one of the
reasons I really like it is that the
Stan developers have spent a lot of time
building tools to make it useful there
are lots of Diagnostics for models so
you can tell if it's fitting well it'll
give you lots of warnings to warn you if
things aren't working in your model and
there's a lot of libraries including the
base plot library which I use later on
to visualize the results of your model
so there's an ecosystem to work with so
Stan model has basically three blocks in
the code the data block the parameters
block and the model block so data is
what you're giving it there are things
that aren't estimated during and their
data or values you're providing and so
you have to declare types and stands so
what we'll do is we have our number of
Group one group two observations and our
number of latent dimensions we have our
covariant matrix which is that n times J
by 2 and so this is just the set of
indices for our back for our terms and
then we have our outcome variable here
and then in this case what I'm doing is
I'm simply providing the standard
deviations on the regression code
and the outcome in a real world
situation you probably want to model
these but I thought I'd keep it simple
for this and so much like before this
code has been cut up for presentation
purposes but the complete script is
available online and so next we'll go
through our parameters so we have our
regression coefficients our main effects
are the Group one and group two betas
and then gammas and deltas are our
latent factors so we declare their
dimensionality here and then the
transform predictors block is a variable
that you're not estimating you're
calculating that is its it comes from an
operation on other variables so here
what I do for the linear predictor is
and this was why I created the matrix of
indices is so that what we'll do is
we'll go through the rows of our matrix
and calculate the linear predictor for
each member of Group one group two and
then the dot product of their latent
factors and so what this is is it means
you can use one for loop to go through
the whole matrix finally this is the
model part where you'll declare the
priors on your model so we have our
group one and group two betas and so
we're using the same beta Sigma there
and then for our latent factors we're
just what I did here is I treated each
row as a normal distribution this is the
equivalent of a multivariate normal
model with an identity matrix and the
same for the deltas and then our outer
Co is normally distributed the mean is
the linear predictor and our standard
deviation and the Y Sigma we provided up
top so one of the other reasons Stan is
great is there's this generated
quantities block that you can use for
model checking and what this will do in
this case what we're going to do is
provide it the linear predictor and
simulate new outcome data from the model
we fit and so what this does is this
provides a way to check that our model
fit well so we'll simulate a thousand
draws from our model for each of our
outcome variables and then we'll take
their means and we can basically look to
see how the distribution compares to our
real data and if it looks like it fits
well it should look like our rich
data so the data used I use two versions
of this one where I had 100 members of
group 1 and 20 members of group 2 and
another where I had 20 members of group
1 and 100 members of group 2 I used the
nuts the no u-turn sampling algorithm in
Stan to fit the model that's the MCMC
algorithm I'll what I will say is I use
the variational Bayes algorithm and
sandwich is much faster to initially to
iterate through models initially but not
to do sort of the final inference step
so what I would recommend is if you're
fitting models like this that are
complex and take a little while to fit I
think this one took probably 10 minutes
to fit is start with variational Bayes
see if it you know your posterior
predictive checks look reasonable and
then go to full inference afterwards so
when we do our posterior predictive
checks for our first model you'll see
that they generally look pretty good our
the dart line is the deductr the dart
line is the real data and the light
lines are there are thousand draws and
so I ran this with four chains so we
actually have 4,000 draws one thousand
for each of the chains but I only
sampled a thousand from that so that it
would still be somewhat legible and the
same for a model too
one concern with these models is
identification so with the latent
factors the factors themselves are
unidentified which what does that mean
it means there's an infinite number of
possible solutions that could give you
the same dot product in your latent
matrices and the reason that can be a
problem for our sampler because our
sampler is climbing up and down the
hills of our posterior and it might get
caught in some local minima so if you
impose stronger assumptions on your
factors you can get identification but
in this case with our unidentified
parameters it's doing reasonably well so
we can then look at our mean squared
error which is we calculated this from
our posterior draws from the generated
quantities block we compared our actual
Y outcomes to the predicted outcomes and
we see that our mean squared error is
about to consistently which makes sense
because our Y Sigma we set
- in our model now we're going to get
hierarchical so our basic factorization
machine assume all of our parameters
were independent they were all
distributed normally with a mean of zero
and a standard deviation of one and they
were uncorrelated hierarchical models
that you share parameters within groups
and you explicitly model the correlation
between members so for example going
back to my country here my example you
can think of this model the correlation
between countries and this is great
because sharing parameters means you're
sharing information with the caveat that
more parameters means more computation
time so this is the math for a
hierarchical model and I'll walk you
through this so we first have our house
car outcome model this is the same as it
was before as is a beta model but for
our latent factors you'll now see that
we're working in with vectors the
distributed multivariate normal and we
have priors over the means and
covariances so our means are just
distributed standard normal and I show
you this because this way they're they
don't get too big if you did something
like a Koshi or a student t prior that's
a heavier tail prior but the sampling
can sort of wander off in space and it
won't fit as well particularly because
these are these latent factors so
smaller scale still works here and then
our covariance is decomposed into a
standard deviation and a correlation
matrix and this is a little easier at
least for me to wrap my head around a
covariance matrix can be is real valued
and I can't really think in terms of
covariances it's very weird to me to
think of a covariance as being negative
to thousands or something but if you can
decompose it into a standard deviation
and a correlation matrix those are
things I understand so we use this lkj
prior over the correlation matrix for
each of our latent factors and in
Staniel actually work with the cholesky
decomposition of the correlation matrix
for stability reasons what that means is
the onliest if you imagine matrix which
is a square we only work with the lower
triangle then we multiply it by itself
transposed and this gives greater
numeric stability and
fitting and then for our standard
deviations I use a half normal
distribution so that's a truncated
normal we need zero and some standard
deviation set by the user and the same
here our parameter for the lkj
distribution is set by the user so our
data block looks pretty similar to
before except now we have to provide it
a bunch of additional parameters for
standard deviations and correlations and
so we put hard bounds on them and one of
the reasons the hard bounds are nice is
that Stan will throw an error if
something is outside of these bounds so
that you know I used Stan and I've made
mistakes where something goes in and it
initializes randomly and you get like it
uses negative 3421 or something and so
it'll throw an error which tells you
that like you need a tight declaration
so now for our parameters things will
look a little different so we have our
non interactive coefficients again but
then what we'll do is we provide a prior
mean which is an N by K matrix and we
have our standard deviation on our
embedding the correlation matrix for our
factor and we're going to use what's
known as a non centered parameterization
to fit this model and I'll detail that
on the next slide but we'll need this
additional parameter a and so we do this
for both gamma and Delta and so here our
transform parameters block is a little
bigger this is where we're going to
calculate our gammas and Delta's and so
with this not centered parameterization
does is it moves the mean into the
variance estimation and it breaks some
of the correlation among the parameters
that helps the sampler in stand run a
little more quickly so and as an example
of how this can help is at work I was
fitting a discrete choice model and when
I move from a center to a non centric
parameterization model fit went from
taking an hour to taking 15 minutes so
you do get sizable improvements in speed
and model it from
parameterisation and then we'll use the
same indexing as before to calculate the
linear predictor finally for our
coefficients we have they're distributed
normally with a mean of zero and a
standard deviation Beta Sigma we have
our half normal distribution for our
standard deviations on our factors
here's where we use the cholesky
decomposition of the correlation matrix
and then for non centered
parameterization we just use a standard
normal distribution for are hierarchical
means as before you know we'll use a
standard normal here and we are filling
it as vectors so our outcome is
distributed normally with our linear
predictor and our Y Sigma so when we fit
this model again we see if it's pretty
well again you have to worry a little
bit about identification but Stan
provides helpful Diagnostics on that
front and we can see with our mean
squared error again it's about two so so
far I've largely some showing you
simulations but now we're gonna fit a
model to some real data so the data set
I use is from famous political science
article and ethnicity insurgency and
civil war it's by James V Ron and David
Lee Clayton it's a 2003 American
political science review article it's
incited like 8,000 times and the goal of
the article was to understand the
relationship to ethnic fractionalization
and the onset of civil war the reason
it's great for factorization machine is
it's country here data so you have two
categorical variables from all countries
in the world 1946 to 1999 and the data
encode of publicly available
the initial article for logistic
regression in Stata yes data but we'll
use our factorization machine we have to
modify our existing factorization
machine code a little bit we'll have to
use logistic regression instead of our
OLS that we've been using and we'll have
to add a way to bring in additional
covariance for this model we no longer
just have fixed effects so the code for
this is also online this code will
hopefully be perhaps the most helpful
for you if you're using these in sort of
a day-to-day application so our outcome
here is at rare events outcome they're
only about one percent of the
observations are civil war onset and one
of the things we do when we fit the
model is you based basically the
assumption in the data is that you can
only have one civil war at a time so a
country drops out of the data set after
a civil war on set while it still has a
war ongoing so what I I fit the model I
evaluated them using log loss and log
lost much like mean squared error mean a
zero is better and so we see the
factorization machine has a lower log
loss but perhaps what was most
interesting to me is plotting this the
outcome the outcome categories this is
on the left is zero on the right is one
red is predictive probabilities from the
logistic progression black is from the
factorization machine what we see is
that the factorization machine in the
case of the one was much better able to
give you probabilities closer to one one
and outcome actually a heard if you
occurred if you look at the logistic
regression you'll see that just about
all the particular probability czar
pretty close to zero and so it fits
better which is certainly in my mind at
least an argument for it and then the
other thing that factorization machines
are great for is your latent factors you
can plot them because you do have these
leading factors so the first technique I
used to plot them was an old technique
from the 60s called salmon mapping and
so the advantage of salmon mapping is
that it preserves nearby distances at
the cost of farther away distances
whenever you pick a technique like this
it's always going to have trade-offs
like that so we can see sort of this is
the overall plot and what I'll do here
is I'll zoom in on this hairball and so
one of the things you can do with this
is you can evaluate to see if there are
patterns in your data
may have missed in this case it didn't
really seem like it but it can be
helpful as a diagnostic both to help
understand your data and to visualize it
if you're showing stakeholders also I
used a more modern technique known as
you map which projects your high
dimensional data onto a lower
dimensional manifold it's simply another
way of visualizing data you could also
use something like PCA or t-sne and
zooming in here
there might be a pattern but you know
you sort of have to leave this to sort
of a substantive interpretation to
understand it so I wanted to wrap this
up you know I talked about factorization
machines where you extend your
generalized linear models with a matrix
factorization on your residuals and I've
talked through two versions one with
factors distributed normally with
standard normally in the second where
we've used hierarchical model and I've
shown how to use dimensionality
reduction to apply your factors
everything I've shown so far here
there's only been two interaction terms
if you want to extend beyond that you
have to start to look at tensor
factorization I wish you the best of
luck with that the math gets scary but
one implementation of this I've seen our
exponential machines which are in
tensorflow and Python so I wanted to
thank everyone for coming the kodan
slides are available here and you can
find me on twitter at my last name
questions that time oh you know it's
gonna be a question right grab this can
use that one sure testing testing Hey
almost like comparing the I am this
isn't out-of-sample okay not in not in
this case no that's a good question I
think one of the advantages here is if
you do have say the country your
interactions is this would be less
likely to overfit as the factorization
helps regularize your two constituent
turns and i also think this is where
like the Bayesian priors can be helpful
for their regularizing effect
I I'm struggling to understand just
because of how the factors are set up
like no priors it does so the question
is how do you put a prior on a leading
parameter when you have domain knowledge
is that so that's there's no one right
answer to this a lot in a lot of cases
the best way to think of it is to sort
of be conservative with your model fit
that is you do want to pick something if
theory tells you sort of you think
certain dimensions will matter so in our
five dimensional model if you think if
you're in say psychology and you're
doing factor analysis on personality
types you might set a distribution that
reflects say an ordering or that
reflects that you know you expect one
thing to dominate the others so or if
you don't know say the number of factors
you could use a sparsity inducing prior
or something like a horseshoe prior and
what that will do is force parameters
towards zero if they're not adding
additional information
Hey so what like scale of data obviously
you have to know a ton of data what what
types of scales so so I would say at
least as I've implemented it the
thousands about thousands to tens of
thousands it's also not instantaneous
particularly if you don't care about
uncertainty estimates you could estimate
it with stochastic gradient descent and
just get predictions but if you wanted
to do sort of a full Bayesian model like
this it'll take a little longer if you
wanted to also if you wanted to use
variational Bayes it'll fit a lot faster
so the models I was fitting here as I
mentioned I think took about 10 minutes
using MCMC they took about 30 seconds to
a minute using variational Bayes and so
the trade-off is variational Bayes
sometimes fails and weird ways but the
upshot is is it's fast and you can do
these sort of calibration
you know posterior predictive checks to
see if it's working for you
we can't they
I wonder so I haven't used these on a
real-world question yet I sort of took
this talk because I wanted to learn
about factorization machines and it was
a great forcing mechanism to commit
myself one place I have thought about
using them is where I work we have a big
discreet choice model so a discrete
choice model you have choices and you
have individuals and so you could have
in addition to your standard variables
for your covariance you could have the
latent factors in the factorization
machine for your choices a friend who
works in election modelling they do
something like that for your choosing
between candidates so you have
individual factors and candidate factors
last chance all right
all right that's the case I notice you
didn't I just finished Stan yes there's
so I use the are Stan package and what
that is is it provides the C++ headers
for Stan so you write Stan code and it
takes care of all the passing things
back and forth between our and Stan
there's also a Python version called PI
Stan if you prefer Python and what's
great is Stan itself is its own language
and it works in its own script so you
could write both a Python wrapper and an
R wrapper to the same stand script yeah
and I think there are a couple other
lengths yeah and there's statist and two
stand we have an annual scam workshop
the depart of the Meetup
we didn't have this past year expand you
to find space but it's 55 space for a
three-day workshop baby yep we're going
to be putting on head workshop by the
people who develop Stan talking Jonah
Kaveri Android gentleman is usually
involved in this Rob trend Gucci every
year changed up a little bit but it's
like Jonah and Angie are pretty much
mainstays Sabbat coming up maybe March
or April maybe what kind of work in a
second there was a hand here that I'm
working on over there Thanks
hierarchical or the yeah this one yeah
partially because that's how I simulated
it partially because I wanted up
partially because that's how I simulated
it so I wanted to see if you know it
worked if I saw if I knew what the
answer was partially it was also because
I wanted a more conservative fit here
simply because those are the muse on the
latent factors and so I didn't want
latent parameters blowing up in the
estimation yes
so I was thinking it those who are sort
of just coming to this for the first
time if you could suggest one reference
yes so statistical rethinking by Richard
Mikkel wreath the second edition is
coming out this winter at some point I'm
not sure exactly when but it is a
fantastic book and part of the reason
it's great is he's an anthropologist so
he writes a book for someone who wants
to use this but sort of trusts the math
works I compare it to a lot of Bayesian
cookbooks sort of start or a Bayesian
statistics books are like cookbooks that
assume that you have a cow you need to
slaughter and then you need to build a
fire statistical rethinking is like you
have a kitchen and you want to cook a
hamburger
M C l al r EA th
pretty sure the meetup group had like a
study group around that book of your two
ago and there's a github repo my hacker
github organization the people who are
working on that Michael were you in
there yeah so talk to them experts you
can point you to where the Canary boys
or it's CRC yeah it's the red book
series and you talked about needing the
interaction with PETA 3 and so on
suddenly I had a flashback to doing
analysis of variants we're not together
the interaction all that it's
insignificant there the corresponding
sum of squares is so small that it's
insignificant so I was wondering how do
you know that Peter 3 actually matters
so I think there are sort of two ways to
answer that one is you know you can sort
of look for say coefficient size or some
measure of uncertainty on the parameter
the second is sort of substantive if
this interaction is sort of
substantively meaningful to this say the
decision you're trying to make that
would be what you would use
to be tougher getting non-zero yes if
anybody wants to do a study curve about
any text out there or any topic the
meetup gonna facilitate that we have to
know the slack channel for the meetup we
have lots of private repos on get up you
can make that use up and it does make
small groups you give them to find space
you at night and out of it tell you this
stuff so if you actually are interested
in doing a study group belt this or any
other book that's out there get in touch
with myself or a mother or Michael and
will sort of facilitate yeah yeah
Michael maybe you want to revise the
group on that one come talk to us we'll
add you to the site and we'll start I'm
not getting every phone have added
together or any other book to by the way
some of the great things out there now
that seems like maybe you've tried out a
lot of things for fun I have a hundred
twenty eight gigabytes of RAM on my
computer and I only use like eight of
them because they're really efficient do
you recommend what I should play around
with them stand that would use my memory
something with a lot of parameters so
you could try taking something like this
and scaling it to a really big data set
and seeing what that can do for you
something like when a one of this a film
prediction data sets and seeing what
sorts of hyper parameter common
combinations or different sort of
shrinkage priors how those can affect
model fit
oh yeah you know the cover of bd83
calling the Gulman and ribbons book that
has the birthday problem birthday
problem but like I'm in analysis of
birthdays faces there's a parameter for
every single day of the year because in
365 parameters plus you have lots of
other parameters so the model has like
you said a lot of parameters go ask me
if I filter grampers excellent okay
we're gonna be da 30 great hand all the
way the back if you can chop go for it I
think it's got a lot of
sure so the question for those of you
who didn't hear it was basically if you
have really big data do you need Bayes
is that a fair and so it's a good
question and I think if you have you
know say a million independent
observations you probably don't need
base but if you're in a situation where
say you have lots of subgroups in your
data and you mail so you may have a
million observations but it's because
you have a hundred thousand groups with
only ten members each that might be when
you'd want Bayes because then you can do
something like the hierarchical modeling
that would let you share information
across your parameters and sort of
further improve your estimates
so at a high level I liked modeling to
answer questions but I'm happy to give
you a more in-depth answer offline after
the talk yeah
[Applause]